quick intro i i did raise solar cars i
will say i was not max for stop and
actually driving them i was on the
support team and helping to design and
build them i also actually worked as uh
inspector for the races for a number of
years
many other things about me there um
done one or two things um
okay
so uh one of the things that i found is
a lot and myself included a lot of
engineers a lot of scientists a lot of
data scientists you build uh scripts or
tools to do your own work to help you
figure something out uh to
you know calculate something uh and then
that could be useful to other people so
you get thinking well what if i was to
make this into a product something that
i can sell and you know give to other
people and they can use it and they can
use all this work i've done over and
over again
now i've
i've done that with charge sim and i'll
tell you about that in a second um
oftentimes these type of scripts can
start off as excel
it may sound silly but often it works
really well because everybody's got
excel on their computer you can just
hand it to someone most people know a
little bit about it and they can get it
going if you do python that works with
some people your colleagues but handing
out python scripts to you know third
parties general public gets very
difficult and so then you need to build
a lot of infrastructure around that in
order to turn it into a product that
other people can use
for this presentation i'm going to give
kind of a helicopter view on this we're
going to jump into a few details of the
implementation there's an awful lot
about this
but i'll touch on a couple points to
think about if you're planning to do
that
so quick introduction to charge sim
so charging is about two years old now
and it started off as a analysis script
to help solve a problem and we've turned
it into a software as a service tool
that we sell to clients and then they're
able to use it to go and do their own
analysis
now we solve a very specific problem
it's not a problem that i suspect anyone
in the room has and if you do come and
talk to me um it's uh if you're buying
let's say 100 electric buses anyone
no
okay i didn't think so uh you want to
figure out how many chargers you need
because these things will run fifty
hundred thousand two hundred and fifty
thousand each and so if you can figure
out that for your hundred buses maybe
you're okay with eighty of them or
seventy of them that's a big deal also a
big deal for your uh what you're asking
your electric company for are you asking
for two megawatts are you asking for
five megawatts that can be a twenty
thousand dollar a month difference
twenty thousand euro a month difference
so it uh it gets interesting for these
the people solving that
so this is kind of what what i do and
now
um next
uh i'll uh i'll talk about how we do it
and some of the things quick disclaimer
get get this over uh get it out of the
way uh we do have some promotional
credit from aws so i will talk about
some amazon stuff that happens to be
what we're using um so i don't have a
totally unbiased view on that but um
i'll i'll explain some of the trade-offs
and for most of these things you know
google and azure and there's third-party
tools that can do a lot of these
functions as well
um
yeah
so there are obviously advantages to
have everything on the same platform
that if you're you know you have one
login system and one billing system for
everything that's quite helpful
so the way to think about this to start
is the the script that you've perhaps
built your python notebook your set of
scripts that helps you figure out
whatever your problem is data analytics
that sort of thing
that's the center here that's this this
core of in in my case it's a simulation
engine
but in order to get users to be able to
work with it we need to be able to add
a bunch of things so for the simulations
we need to allow a user to set up a
configuration and say look where where
do the you know how many buses are we
using what type of batteries do they
have there's a lot of these questions
and the same thing if you have your
analysis script you've got to be able to
load in all the data
and then get that into the same uniform
format that your simulation engine or
your your
analysis tool can work with
on the other end so we've got a front
end part for that in our case it's react
and then lambda functions and then on
the other end after the script is run
you collect all the data you've you've
come up with your brilliant insightful
answer and now you need to share it and
explain it with the users and so they
need some tools to explore that data to
plot it to look at it
quickly and easily
next
okay
big lesson that i i have discovered in
doing this
is there is a massive difference in the
amount of effort between a script that
you build for your own use something
that you can use and you know if it if
you get a bug then you can just figure
it out yourself and solve it to
something that you could give to
somebody else to use and charge money
for and as a product and there is a a
massive additional amount of effort and
in this presentation i'll talk about
some of the pieces that go into that
extra effort to um
that you we need to put in
and i will also note
and as the ceo of a small company uh
there is also an enormous amount of work
in sales and in marketing and i'm
excluding all of this
so this presentation we're assuming you
have your helpful business partner who
can sell the stuff if you're doing that
as well uh that's a lot of time
uh next slide
so give you a quick idea what the
architecture we're working with is so
you have uh to frame some of it uh later
front end uh we use react um because
it's a nice uh there's a lot of people
using it so there's a strong base of
libraries and it's um uh yeah it's
relatively yeah so it's relatively easy
to work with and it gives a nice fast
interactive
experience for the users
then
we're using
amazon's api gateway so that manages all
of the
different api end points that the front
end is pulling the data from i'll talk
about that in a little bit more depth
later then we have a whole set of lambda
functions which will then do database
queries trigger uh the simulation engine
which runs in uh it's a it's a docker
container that amazon starts up and runs
so fargate um and so that gives you a
quick idea of how we've built the tool
but then remember uh in our going from
our initial script is is in this this
box in orange up at the top with the
simulation and then the rest of this
we've had to build all of this to make
it accessible to users
uh next slide
so
users unfortunately add an awful lot of
requirements to your system beyond just
a python script for instance that you
can run on your own desktop because
users have these weird expectations like
um
you know you you kind of want to make
sure that the right person is using it
and that they have perhaps even paid you
to be able to do this that you don't
want it open for everyone unless you're
deliberately doing open source for
instance
users are also uh pretty they kind of
like it when they can access only their
data and only their data and they would
rather not seeing or they would rather
that somebody else doesn't see their
data
so this means you need to add security
you need to add logins you need to add
authentication authorization we'll talk
about that in a bit more depth
the other huge problem that comes up uh
is if you've built something yourself
you understand all of it deeply and you
can figure out if anything goes wrong or
you can understand all of those little
trade-offs and the way it thinks is
obvious to you because it's the way you
think
however you start getting users involved
they don't understand all of that and
you know if if the vulcan mind belt
where you could just you know touch
their face and imbue all of your
knowledge into your user uh you wouldn't
have this problem unfortunately that
doesn't work
so we need to do documentation and quite
a bit of it in order to make this
accessible and i'll talk about that uh
in a bit as well
next slide
so
turning our user needs into sort of more
detailed requirements and into
implementations uh security comes in two
parts
one is authentic so some of the things
i'll talk about here uh there's
authentication and authorization and
those are different and i'll explain a
little bit about that we'll talk about
documentation and a couple things that i
find really help with reliability and
again because if something that you have
built crashed you can understand it you
can fix it you can try again
if something crashes for your user
yeah you need to deal with that so next
slide
so
security is actually two different
halves of a problem one is
authentication
and then the other one is authorization
now
authentication is saying are you really
who you say you are
and this is making sure that i know that
you are the right person this is dealt
with with things like uh two-factor
authentication with usernames with
passwords so now i i know that you say
you are uh you say you are bob and i'm
really sure i figured out that you
really are bob
the other part of this is authorization
and this is figuring out who is allowed
to see what information so
congratulations you are bob we figured
this out
but are you allowed to see project
number 75
it might be that carol owns project
number 75 but maybe she has said that
she should share that with you and so
now we need to figure that out so next
slide
so um yeah authentication talked about
this a little bit of what the problem is
my general advice for this is don't do
it yourself
there's a lot of complexities that get
thrown into this like password
recoveries like sending sms texts all
over the place if you're doing
two-factor authentication
um a lot of
details around encryption and
you know managing managing the identity
properly
and this is also a super super standard
problem uh just about every web app has
this type of problem and so what that
means is there's a bunch of tools out
there that can provide authentication
services for you we happen to use amazon
cognito but there's octa google and
azure have their own identity and login
systems you can use single sign-in from
for instance github like the pi data
site does
there can also be gdpr implications you
know if you know a lot of personal
information about users then you need to
manage that properly
and all of these work uh mostly with
what's called a jwt token so i'll talk
about that in a little bit more depth
and so this is a nice way to separate
out the authentication from the rest of
your tool
next slide
so as i mentioned there's actually a lot
of complicated parts of authorization
also think about how do you freeze an
account how do you change access rights
you know you need interfaces and you
need ways to do all of this
in order to manage your users properly
next slide
so
other side of this is authorization so
now we're figuring out congratulations
you're bob are you allowed to see this
project uh are you allowed to edit it
are you allowed to view it are you
allowed to do you know are you allowed
to add uh make it much more complicated
does your license level allow you to do
that or do you need to pay more money
first
next slide
so to to give an example that we will
typically run into
uh there may be
uh our typical end user is for instance
a transit agency and they're planning
out their electric bus infrastructure
and so there may be a project and their
staff may be involved with that they may
also have a consulting firm involved
with that who can edit it
that we may be supporting the project
directly and so then we may have view or
edit permissions
and so there's all these different
combinations the consulting company may
also be working for a completely
different agency and so we need to have
an authorization system that lets us
figure out who is allowed to see what
next slide
we do this with groups
and in our case we attach the groups to
the jwt token which i'll talk about in a
little bit
but there's a variety of ways to do this
uh i don't know if any of you have
worked with uh sap systems but they have
an absolutely massive authorization or
uh yeah absolutely massive authorization
system yeah i see some i see some nods
there that their
fellow uh yeah other people who have
unders who have explored this uh because
you've got all these permissions if you
if you're purchasing something who's
allowed to author you know who's allowed
to approve spending and who actually
writes the check and so forth
so let's talk about the next slide so
now i'll quick uh quick introduction to
jwt tokens how many are already using
jwt tokens are already familiar with
them
okay i see maybe a quarter of the hands
going up so that's that's good uh there
i find
a fairly effective solution to this also
because it allows you to put all of this
off
authorize or the authentication problem
you can hand off to uh one of these
third-party providers fairly easily with
it so what we do is we the user
initiates a login goes to for instance
our service in our case uh cognito
cognito says yes okay i've logged you in
i've maybe i've done a one-time password
maybe i've done a just a password i've
maybe put in some security on your ip
address whatever is appropriate
and it generates a cryptographically
signed and time and dated token that
says okay whoever holds this token is
now allowed to access the system for you
know one hour or whatever you've set it
up
the user is then able to take that um
put that into the header of their api
calls which then go to the api gateway
and then the in the amazon case the api
gateway will actually validate that
token itself you can also put in custom
uh validators that compare the
cryptographic signature that comes on
the user's token with the um the public
key of the authority that's signing it
so the the authentication or the
authorization provider
and what that means is that you only
ever trigger uh your own functions your
own lambda functions that are for
instance reading your database
after you have fully approved that this
is a valid logged in user and so this
simplifies it and separates the concerns
quite a bit because for instance
this part the user will be for instance
a standard react library in our case we
use amplify but there's several of them
out there to deal with the passwords and
login
the the jwt server is usually provided
as a service as i say this is you know
could be cognito
similar
uh the token validation uh again in
amazon that's the api gateway system
takes care of that by itself and then we
only really get to it when we get to the
um the back end system doing the
authorization and actually executing the
function and so those are kind of two
steps that we need to implement and the
rest of it is largely taken care of by
existing libraries
um
yeah uh okay so i uh i thought i had
more on that but no let's move to
documentation so
um
help is enormously important to allow
users to use a tool so we have a user
interface it's got all sorts of
different inputs
typical one would be you need to put in
what's the battery capacity of the bus
that you're planning to buy
so we say well you've got to input that
in but
there may be some details about that
there may be some complexities or what's
the unit um
capacity is a relatively easy one but we
have all sorts of other inputs which may
be a little bit more complicated and
then the user needs to find out how that
works and so we have a little help
bubble there and we happen to use a tool
called elev dot io
and they provide sort of all the help
file or they manage all the help files
and provide response to
allow the user to rate them say this one
isn't very good keep track of revisions
that kind of thing
so there's a variety of different
solutions for that but it's definitely
one to consider in in building your
system
also keep in mind you need things like
training
programs you may need user manuals
depending on the complexity of your
product uh you'd like to think
everything can be beautiful and super
obvious and easy to learn
and if you're building it it usually is
to you because you've been building it
uh but for other people they they need
all of that support
and a big rule that i have found helps
with this is the ticket isn't closed
until the documentation is done
so uh don't don't or you know don't
don't allow yourself to move on uh onto
other projects until
it is really usable by a user including
all of the information needed for it
and also starting the documentation can
be a way to help refine and think
through the requirements for the
function you're implementing
next
oh
okay
now talk about um
you know getting the system to be robust
and reliable so this is also one of the
things that i found going from something
that i use myself
if i hit a bug i can just deal with it
if i give it to a user it needs to be
really stable so there's a couple things
we can do to
improve that
it's also obviously essential essential
for the clients to trust the outcome
that they're getting there's a few
things we can do uh we can have feedback
mechanisms and i'll talk about some of
those we can do testing so unit and
overall testing i won't talk too much
about i won't talk about that
um
reducing the chance of errors and that's
where i find schemas and static typing
are really useful on the one hand
working in python we're like no no we
all love dynamic typing but as you get
towards production i i find that
actually becomes more of a liability and
so
putting in more static typing helps next
slide
so
users tend to find their own way to use
the tool and i always get surprised by
this i i give it to a user and then
they've figured out some other way that
they can enter something in and it could
be it could be really simple it could be
you know we want to put in the power of
the charger well is it 22 or 22
kilowatts or 22 000 i mean all of these
could be valid
but if you don't check it if you don't
enforce it if you don't make sure that
for instance it's a number and not a
string
these can turn into bugs and this is
where things like static typing
and schemas are really important so the
sooner you constrain all of these the
less problems you have next slide
so um schemas and static typing again
kind of annoying of coming from python
my experience is generally you know
python is is great for getting things
going really fast but then without the
uh the static typing it becomes a
liability longer term and it becomes
more difficult to maintain
if i look at something like javascript
which is basis for react it's then
weakly statically typed so it's very
flexible about saying oh well that
you put one two three as a string but i
think maybe that was supposed to be a
number or maybe that was supposed to be
false and you know kind of massaging it
a little bit it also uses undefined
quite a bit and
i find that actually it works okay on a
front end because it tends to it tends
to try and push through bugs uh if it
hits them occasionally you get not a
numbers that type of thing but in the
back end uh that can just turn into a
liability uh and then javascript is
strongly typed or sorry java would be
strongly typed and having worked with
that that actually has an advantage that
you hit a lot of problems at compile
time that in other languages you
wouldn't see until you are actually
executing the code
so type hinting in python and that's
becoming increasingly popular i think in
the later like three nine uh they're
implementing more of that but even in
earlier versions it's really helpful
because your ide will probably coach you
on a lot of this and it actually helps a
lot just with the documentation and code
completion and speeding things up
uh javascript of course has typescript
which is the typed version of it
starting to implement some of that again
it can be really annoying but it's
finding bugs before you hand it to users
to find bugs next slide
scheme as an api
so the api gateway that we use we are
able to we're defining all of it in a
tool called swagger
and this is now open api so it is a very
long
yaml i believe file
that
defines exactly what the interface is
going to be
and if that schema is not met it won't
even trigger it so next slide
so for instance if a user tries to send
in a message where it's got a string
instead of an integer for instance
it's just not even going to get through
so they can't ask for project number
semicolon drop table users
and so this is quite helpful
this can get very long
but it also generates documentation for
your system because you can now see uh
when you go back six months later you
know what was was that supposed to be an
integer was that's you know what were
the valid enum values in there that kind
of thing so you can put all of that in
and so i'd highly recommend using
something like a schema to uh to
validate your inputs and to help
generate your api next slide
errors
so this is a big one um
do we know how we call what what this is
from or how it's caused i mean i might
have a guess at it because i made it
however if i'm a user i have no idea and
i have no idea how to fix it so i've got
to deal with errors next slide
so what we need to do this is we need
some kind of a logging library we need a
way to collect all of these problems and
handle them
and i'm running out of time so i'm going
to go next slide
so i think of errors in three categories
one is a user error this is nothing
wrong with the code this is something
that the user has done that is wrong and
you just need to
explain it to the user and coach them to
do it better
this could be something like saying i
want to try and simulate 35 buses when i
only have 30 parking spots
it's just not going to work
and so you just need to tell the user
yeah i just can't do that you've got to
change one of these numbers to make this
work
second type is a software assertion and
i put these all over in the code in this
case we're doing a physical simulation
so we know that for instance
conservation of energy should probably
be respected
and if something in the code says that
that's not true
then almost certainly the code is wrong
so we can check that and we are much
better off to hit that stop the system
and just say you know we have a bug
we're going to solve it then we are to
present a wrong answer to a user
um the last one is then the the software
error where it's just it's going to
outright crash and it's something that
you know hopefully the compiler or
you've earlier picked out but they
happen occasionally and it's just the
system doesn't work next slide
um
easy the thing that i have found really
helpful for this is just encapsulating
everything and then using in our case we
use a tool called century and it adds a
library uh that you can add into the
headers to all of basically all of your
files and all of your languages and then
anytime an error happens anywhere with
users with your own system with the back
end it gets fed into uh the century
system and you get a report of it
and this is excellent because i've even
had cases where i get a century report
that a user has hit some kind of bug and
i'm able to very quickly find that fix
the error and frankly keep the user
happy by saying yep we understand what
went wrong
we don't need to spend a lot of time can
you replicate that also users often
won't uh report uh all of the bugs that
they see or all of the errors they'll
they'll work through it they'll find
workarounds it's not their job to make
your tool better so getting a good
overview of where problems might be is
really helpful next
user errors you need to tell the user as
i mentioned
and we need to do this in a clear way i
find it helps a great deal to have
a error code name that's reasonably uh
verbose so it's actually a readable name
that explains what the type of error is
next and i'll talk about how to write
error messages and i think of three
things that should be in there
one is we have an error code so that we
can link it to our help files to our
documentation two is we want to know
what the error is okay there there
wasn't enough parking
now we need to explain to the user why
it happened okay you were simulating 80
buses with 30 parking spots and it just
won't work so you have to explain that
to them and then the third part is how
to fix it okay you can go back and you
can adjust the number of parking spaces
you can adjust the number of buses and
so when i write documentation for error
files i make sure to include all of
these three elements and i even have it
in a template that they all fit on
exactly the same approach because we
want this to be usable to the the users
need to be able to understand this next
slide
so conclusion uh
moving to a product is a huge amount of
effort uh and it requires thinking about
user interfa user interface user
accounts robustness um and there is a
huge gap between the script that you've
built for yourself and something that
you can hand to someone outside and that
they can go ahead and use it but these
are some of the tricks and some of the
the tools that i've found to to help
accelerate that
next slide
so uh other shameless plug here uh we
are growing we are looking for
developers um and
so this is we are working on a very
geeky way to help save the world and
reduce greenhouse gases by transitioning
more vehicles to electric at lower cost
we're also a very small company so
unfortunately we're looking for people
who can be really effective without a
large number of project managers scrum
managers or scrum masters middle
managers uh carefully focused on their
organization or their their okr of
getting a larger car specifically the a6
um and yeah so check out check out
chargesim.com or come talk to me later
if you're interested next
any questions
[Applause]
any questions for andrew okay yeah
i was wondering if you're also treating
your developers as users
uh
yeah i was very small company at the
moment so there uh there isn't too many
uh choices there but uh
that's actually one of the key things i
find in like i do a lot of the software
development and i also do consulting
work with clients helping with this
and i find the consulting work is really
essential to get that feedback because i
understand what the problems are and i'm
working closely with the other
consulting companies that are involved
to understand the problems so uh yeah
getting that that short feedback loop i
think is is i mean it's frankly that's
the huge advantage that small companies
have compared to big companies all of
those layers of management that i joked
about i mean that that is a as as you
get to a bigger company that ends up
being an unfortunate necessity and it
slows things down
um
yeah yeah and one thing for example we
are doing is you make the python package
available
to users in your company i guess for you
it's not such a big problem but if you
have a big company you you know you
would just want to install the simulator
yeah
yeah so there
and there i i think i had it in the
effort slide that there's also the
effort required for colleagues so um you
know for instance the if you're just
handing out the script it's got to be
documented the errors have to be clear
uh the user authentication may not be a
problem because it's just like yeah if
you have access to the company uh server
then that's taken care of um so there's
different yeah different parts of that
yep
yep uh question about documentation uh
how do you help like focus on
documenting the right thing because i
feel like often you end up documenting
everything that's easy to document but
the actual tricky things end up not and
you have like too long didn't read the
documentation but when i searched for
something it wasn't in there yeah it's
you're absolutely right it is super easy
to write a document that explains what a
kilowatt is it is way more complicated
to explain how this interacts with
everything else and why it's really
important
um
yeah i don't have a it's a good question
i don't have a a brilliant answer on it
i think part of that is also on kind of
user feedback and like training users
what are the parts that they don't
understand and then helping to you know
using that as a feedback path to improve
the documentation
yeah any other question
um yeah i was wondering if you also
physi test your code to find potential
books
yeah so we have quite a quite a bit of
unit testing built in and then we have
sort of standard test cases that we run
so there's quite a few things that we've
put in for that i didn't touch upon it
uh in much depth here simply because
i've got half an hour to discuss a huge
subject
apparently
apparently that's the end of the half
hour but yeah
now we can take one more short question
if there is any other
nope okay yeah
also about documentation so you
suggested to start with the
documentation right which i also see the
point but on the other hand if you are
working on exploration
activity then you really have to do
several iterations to be able to reach
to what you are looking for so how do
you see that um
i think of that there are
yeah
so there are activities that i see as
more of a research activity versus more
of a development activity so the
research activities i don't worry about
it so much because i know i'm as you say
i'm exploring i'm trying to figure out
if there's really something useful there
and so there i'm kind of doing it more
you know from for internal iteration as
opposed to once you say okay this is a
feature i want to launch customers then
i know the documentation has to be an
important part of it so i just put it in
that kind of separate out the research
activity from the development activity
because the research activity also ends
up
development at the end right so
well that's yeah so if i if i think
about it there the i would call it a
research activity that i'm exploring is
this worth doing and i have maybe a 50
percent uh expected chance of success if
i now say all right this is something
i'm going to give to users then it turns
into more of the development activity
and in the case of this tool there's
often um
quite a bit of work that happens in kind
of the simulation engine
you know what what new features can we
simulate that we can do as
the research activity but then when it
gets to adding all the buttons and you
know then then it's going to be user
facing and then we really have to go to
kind of development mode and say it's
got to be documented it's got to have x
number of tests and all of the the good
things you do to make sure it's ready
for production
awesome
you